the music speaks to something so human
even the people who hold you underneath
their boot can't help the sing-along
this music just connected when we first
came to New York the Apollo was the
first place we want to go that's just a
taste of the new HBO documentary the
Apollo look back at the 85-year history
the theater that's been the cultural hub
of Harlem the world renowned venue
became famous not just for hosting music
legends and cultural and political icons
but for Amateur Night which launched
countless careers still that glorious
past could not prevent the apollo from
merely going under a story of struggle
told by bose who lived it this is a wall
of legends everyone up here has
performed here over and over again to
sold-out houses if you want the story of
the Apollo Theater Louie Armstrong Duke
Ellington they all please you've got to
get the skinny from this man you are
living history I've literally watched
history being made Billy Mitchell has
been a Wallflower here for 54 years
I'm the Apollo ambassador officially
he's even written a book about it from
the wall of Legends to the tree of hope
a good luck tree stump performers rub
he's just about seen it all I ran
errands for a group that Berry Gordy had
brought here it was a tool called the
Motown review review yeah
like the supreme supreme okie bought
three the Vandellas Marvin Gaye and this
very energetic visually impaired kid by
the name of little Stevie Wonder his
memories and those from dozens of others
I couldn't believe that there wasn't a
documentary about the Apollo already
were mine for historical treasure by
oscar-winning filmmaker Roger Ross
Williams it was an overwhelming task how
do you condense 85 years into 90 minutes
I realized that our music lifted us out
of oppression originally a theater for
burlesque the rebranded Apollo opened on
January 16 1934 and catered specifically
to African Americans billing itself as a
place where stars are born and legends
are made we use the music and art to
sort of voice our pain our struggle as
black people and that was the way I
wanted to tell the story of the Apollo
to put it in context of what was going
on in Harlem and what was going on in
America and how the music from Billie
Holiday singing strange fruit which was
a protest song and the only place she
could sing that song is on the stage of
the Apollo all the way to James Brown
singing I'm black and I'm proud
in 1968 a tumultuous year in America so
that was how I was gonna tell the story
telling that story includes some pretty
infamous tales Ella Fitzgerald Z but she
rubbed this in 1934 Elif is Joe it was
actually the first female to win amateur
at the Apollo from Ella's debut which
launched the precursor to our modern day
star searches
[Music]
everybody watched Showtime at the Apollo
to the man who created amateur night
in-house producer Ralph Cooper owner
Frank Shipman hired the african-american
innovator to reel in talent and as the
documentary shows reel in he did the
Apollo it was more like a university it
was like going to school when Gladys and
I played the Apollo Theater and learned
how to be gracious to the audience what
also comes out just how hard the job was
[Music]
and how which allowed for its success
and ultimately its downfall former owner
Bobby shipment Gladys Knight the first
time I ever played her I paid her $800
for she and the pips for 31 shows the
last time I played her I paid her
$80,000 for 16 shows low-capacity
bankrupted the institution by the
mid-1970s a 1600 seat facility just
couldn't compete with larger venues if
you drove by you wouldn't even know that
the Apollo was alive and operating
Janelle Procope became executive
director of the Apollo after New York
media magnate Percy Sutton failed with
his grand plan to revive the theater in
the early 1990s her partner in
rebuilding former Time Warner chairman
dick Parsons together they came up with
the innovative idea to turn a for-profit
business into a non profit Cultural
Center music will always be at the core
of what we do but we're doing theater
we're doing dance we're doing comedy and
the beauty of that is that's something
that's affordable for the community so
people can say oh what do I want to do
tonight oh I think I'm gonna go to the
Apollo which is where Roger Ross
Williams decided to start his film and I
was like okay
that's it that's the hook so we are here
working and developing between the world
of me by Tana hasi coats in 2017 Ross
Williams captured rehearsals for the
production of a dramatic reading of
Coates memoir then eventually they took
it on the road and think of how Prince's
daughter was now drafted I wrote between
Weldon me because my friend Prince Jones
was murdered in 2000 son I write you in
your 15th year this was the year you saw
Eric garner choked to death for selling
cigarettes this reading is a blueprint
of what may come but projects in the
Apollo's future think about this there
is no other Performing Arts Center in
the country that focuses on the African
American narrative telling our stories
so between the world and me that's the
beginning of the future I give tours
every day but for Billy Mitchell the
foundation will always be this stage so
there's James Brown Dionne Warwick and
that's Otis Redding sitting in there you
go legends who made it here and the
talented people who continue to break
ground including gonna have you signed
your name on the wall laughs you knew I
was up on stage that's not what's good
singing it what's so great about this
place is everyone has played that stage
from Bono to Paul McCartney to Barack
Obama you just it's it's open to
everyone and what's really awesome is
the future she was talking about they
have are they're in the process of
building two more theaters right next
door in the same block in a building
where the old Victoria Theatre was it's
gonna be just a cultural experience
so many people in that neighborhood in
those walls I guess in the documentary
film the Apollo is available now in HBO